greetings to everyone my name is dhavan
and today i'll be discussing my project
that is based on in silicon analysis of
differentially expressed genes
and their pathway analysis in prostate
cancer before moving forward let me
introduce myself my name is sabil kumar
srivastava and i'm a final year student
pursuing integrated mime tech in
biotechnology from ahmed university
noida
my research interests include omix data
analysis
microbiology cell in molecular biology
nanobiotechnology and artificial
intelligence and machine learning in
healthcare
starting with prostate cancer prostate
cancer
is the second most common cancer
diagnosed in men and the fifth leading
cause of death globally
prostate cancer can be asymptomatic in
its early stages and has a dissolute
course that may only necessitate active
surveillance
prostate cancer incidence and mortality
rates are strongly related to age with
early elderly men with age greater than
65 having the highest incidence rates
in comparison to white men african
american men and african men have the
highest incidence rates and
more aggressive kind of prostate cancer
early stage prostate cancer can be
asymptomatic however common complaints
including difficulty in urinating
decreased frequency and nocturia all of
which are the signs of prosthetic
hypertrophy
because of the exoskeleton in the most
prevalent site of bone with metastatic
illness
more advanced stages of the disease may
present with urine incontinence and back
pain
[Music]
prostate cancer kills an estimated 30
000 men alone in united states each year
recurrent somatic mutations copy number
alterations and oncogenic structural dna
rearrangements such as chromoplexy have
been found in primary prostate cancers
in several studies
point mutations in spop
fox a1 and tp53 as well as copy number
changes in my c rb1
p10
chd1 and e26 transformation specifics
fusions are among the physiological
relevant genes
although
several initial prostate cancer changes
or signatures have been shown to have
prognostic clinical values
potential tumor biomarkers for early
detection and risk assessment of
prostate cancers have been identified
using comprehensive gene expression
profiling
the point tall in 2004
used a cdna microarray based analysis to
stratify tumors into clinically
meaningful subgroups of prostate cancer
which were then linked with tumor grade
stage and pre-operated prostate-specific
antigens that is psa levels
pc
uh
pc81 was found to be involved in
prostate concept progression after
transcriptome profiling sequencing was
performed on a trans prostate cancer
cohort
significant intra tumor heterogeneity
and a lack of understanding of the
molecular mechanisms regulating tumor
growth are barriers to efficient
clinical management of prostate cancer
as a result there has been a surge in
interest in learning more about prostate
cancer pathophysiology during local
and distant human progression in order
to improve diagnostic sensitivity
and therapeutic success in the clinic
transcriptomics genomics and other homic
technologies have enabled this
simultaneous determination of thousands
of molecular characteristics leading to
an improved understanding of molecular
pathophysiology in chronic heterogeneous
diseases such as these
as a result targeted therapeutic
techniques have been developed based on
clinically relevant actionable mutant
genes disease altered pathways and
molecular patterns with prognostic and
predictive importance
molecularly driven therapeutic targets
are predicted to improve intervention in
advanced prostate cancer as a part of
personalized therapy regimens based on
innovative
and more targeted medic guidance guided
by omix-based biomarkers
so the main objective set for this study
is to understand the molecular
complexity of prostate cancer by in
silicon transphobic data analysis
for this we have obtained a data set
from tcga gdc portal via rscript
followed by its normalization followed
by quantile filtering sample
distribution into tumor and normal
species differential expression analysis
enrichment analysis followed by a
pathway analysis
beginning with
the project was started with importing
the tcga violence library followed by
retrieving prostate cancer dataset
the project name given to the data set
is planned so a query was put up on our
studio stating the project title has a
tcga plan under the category of gene
expression with a quantified data type
wherein the quantification has been
performed on illumina highsec with rna
seg data strategy ultimately leading to
a normalized result
once we received the output we
downloaded all the 550 files present in
it followed by preparing an expression
matrix with gene id in the boards and
sample spar code in the columns and
arsene.jeans as result as values
after the summarized experiment library
was summoned to summarize the experiment
that is to incorporate metadata into the
ordinary obtained data including the
clinical data as well
after the incorporation of metadata a
correlation box plot was obtained to
check the outliers that could be run
followed by data normalization and
quartile filtration with a bar of 0.25
that is the quantile cut of 0.25 from
which normal samples that is in
nt samples and tumor sample as the tp
samples were obtained to perform
differential expression
analysis appreciated differentially
expressed genes to obtain from
normalized filtered data by
incorporating the false discovery rate
that is the fdr rate cut off at 0.001
and a log hole change threshold at plus
1.5 whereas for down regulated
expression and
analysis of genes for down regulated
genes the false difference recovery rate
that is the fdr rate was cut off at
0.001 and a log pole change threshold as
minus 0.1
after the dea we performed a gene
ontology enrichment analysis to identify
classes of genes that have been
overexpressed and might have an
association with the disease
once we obtained the upregulated and
down regulated genes with their log-full
change threshold values we moved ahead
with the pathway analysis which
incorporated annotation ontology results
from enrich our web and gene mania
the results obtained were as follows
we started the preprocessing phase by
building an array array intensity
correlation plot the gene expression
matrix which has rows representing genes
and columns representing samples
each entry in the matrix represents the
expression level of a specific gene to
identify a problematic array we created
an aaic plot that defines spearmint's
symmetric squared correlation matrix
between the samples
the color indicates the strength of the
correlation between samples
higher correlations are displayed in
darker colors and lower correlations are
displayed in lighter colors samples
consider outliers are removed according
to this matrix
that is the second part of the figure
that is 1b
a correlation cutoff of 0.25 was used to
determine outlast and then a normalized
process was applied to
the broad gene expression data to
correctly infer expression levels and
avoid errors in the expression
measurements
we then moved on to performing
differential expression analysis wherein
we obtained a total of 695
differentially expressed genes out of
which 265 were ab regulated differential
expressed genes and 4 30 but down
regulated differential expressions
to reduce the underlying biological
processes from the degs we performed an
enrichment analysis using the tcga
analyze enrichment analysis component
function
the tcga borrowing output
showed a bar chart with the number of
genes assigned to the main categories
such as biological processes cellular
components molecular functions and
pathways
the top 20
are shown here for each of them
we then combine the differential
expression data into a single file and
load it on to ilinks for further
analysis
ilynx is an integrative web-based
platform for analysis of comics data and
ignatius of cellular perturbations the
platform facilitates analysis of
user-submitted ohmic signatures of
diseases and cellular components in
context of large compendium of
pre-computed signatures of more than two
hundred thousand as well as mining and
re-analysis of large collection of omix
data sets of more than twelve thousand
pre uh computed signatures and their
connections
islin
workflow integrates vast omix data
resources and a range of analytics and
interactive visualization tools into a
comprehensive platform for analysis of
omics signatures
we uploaded the gene name and its
log fc onto this interface and procedure
to enrich our x2k and gene mania
analysis
nhr is a platform that uniquely
integrates knowledge from many high
profile projects to provide synthesized
information about mammalian genes and
gene sets the platform provides various
methods to compute gene
set enrichment and the results are
visualized in several interactive ways
the results from the end result showed
that ppar signaling pathway and ampk
signaling pathway were most common uh
significantly expressed with ppar
leading the pair with a p-value of 8.64
e minus 8 with an adjusted p-value of
0.000917
[Music]
and ampk stuck with the p value of
1.058 e minus 7
with the adjusted p value similar to the
ppar pathway
ppar that is the peroxisome proliferated
activated receptors are nuclear hormone
receptors that are activated by fatty
acids and their derivatives ppar has
three isotypes that is ppar alpha ppr
beta and ppr gamma
showing different expression patterns in
vertebrates ppr alpha plays an important
role in
clearance of circulating or cellular
lipids via regulation of gene expression
involved in lipid metabolism in liver
and skeletal muscles
ppr beta delta is involved in lipid
oxidation and cellular proliferation and
ppercama
promotes adipocyte differentiation to
enhance blood glucose uptake
the amp activated protein kinase is a
serine therionem kinase that is highly
conserved through evolution ampk system
acts as a sensor for cellular energy
status it is activated by the increase
in the cellular amp
atp amp atp ratio caused by metabolic
stress
that either interferes with atp
production
or the acceleration of atp consumption
several upstream kinases include liver
kinase v1 lkb1 calcium carbomodulin
kinase kinase beta that is camk beta and
egf beta activated kinase one that is
tak1 can activate ampk by phospholiting
a threonine residue on its catalytic
alpha subunit once activated the ampk
leads to a
concomitant inhibition of energy
consuming biosynthetic pathways such as
protein fatty acid and glucose
glucose glycogen synthesis and
activation of atp
producing catabolic pathways such as
fatty acid oxidation and glycolysis
in the activation of emp signaling
pathway ampk can be activated by
upstream ampk kinase and their sites of
action are phosphorylated
by ampk alpha subunit
of 172 sulfide amino acid
nhr also delivered the data for most
significantly ex
differentially expressed genes
associated with most common
differentially expressed pathways that
is ppar and ampk signaling pathways
it was identified that six genes that is
adipoq cd36 pck1 fab p4 aqp7 and plin1
were the significant genes in ppar
signal in pathway and eight genes that
is adipaq cd36 nep slc 2a4
pck1 pfk b1
gys2 and lipe were the significant genes
in ampk signaling pathway
after enrich r we moved on to x2k web
platform for transcription factor
enrichment analysis that is tfea kinase
enrichment analysis that is kea and to
develop an expression to kinase that is
x2k network on the x2k web platform
the x2k web infers upstream regulatory
networks from signatures of
differentially expressed genes
by combining transcription factor
enrichment analysis protein protein
interaction network expansion with
kinase enrichment analysis the x2k web
produces infer networks of transcription
factors proteins and kinases predicted
to regulate the expansion of the input
gene list
the transcription factor enrichment
analysis that is the tfe predicts
transcription factors that are predicted
to regulate the input gene list by
performing gene set enrichment analysis
using different transcription factor
gene set libraries
for example
integrated target genes for
transcription factors are determined by
chipset experiments
the results obtained here are then used
as an input for the next step involved
in the x2k pipeline
for our cohort
the tap predicted that pp arg was a
transcription factor with most
significant
association as it scored
8.01 minus 9 which is the highest value
in the negative scale of myeloxtene
the encoded protein pparg is a
ligand-activated transcription factor
that is involved in the regulation of
adipocyte differentiation and glucose
homeostasis the protein forms a
heterodimer with retinoid x receptors
and binds to dna motives termed as
peroxisome proliferator response
elements to either activate or inhibit
the gene expression
tfea also deduced that pparg target nine
genes from the input list that is aqp7
lipe
cidc
cd36
gos2 fabp4
gpd1
atp1a2 and lep
we then moved on to kinase enrichment
analysis which predicted the protein
kinases that are likely to be the
regulators of the expanded protein
protein net interaction network from the
previous step
the kea perform
enrichment analysis on the list of
proteins from this sub network using
gene set libraries from kinetic
substrate interaction databases
for our cohort the kef predicted that
mapk1 and mapk2
were the two proteins kinases that are
most significant since they scored
3.606 minus 16 and
3.76
seven three six minus fifteen
respectively which was the highest value
in the negative scale of log ten
the two
uh map kinases that play a key role in
the m a pk erp cascade are
mapk1
uh erk2 and mepk3 erk1 they also take
part in the signaling cascade that is
triggered by the activation of kit
and krtl gsfc the
map kinase cascade regulates
transcription translation and
cytoskeletal rearrangements to mediate a
variety of biological processes such as
cell growth addition survival
differentiation depending upon the
cellular context
pfea and kea was then followed by the
expression to kinase network which
displays the inferred upstream
regulatory network predicted to regulate
the input list of genes by integrating
the results from tfea and the kinase
enrichment
the pink nodes in the diagram
of the network represents the top
transcription factors predicted to
regulate the expression of input gene
list the orange nodes represent proteins
that physically interact with the
enriched
transcription factors and correct them
blue nodes represent the top predicted
protein kinase
known to phosphorylate proteins within
the expanded sub network the green
network
shows the edges or links which represent
kinase substrate phosphorylation
interaction between kinases and their
substrates while the grain network edges
represent the physical protein protein
interactions
since we received the differentially
expressed genes from the differentially
expressed pathways ppar ampk signaling
pathway and the differentially expressed
transcription factor that is pparg we
found that there were a few
differentially expressed genes common
between the above three
fabp4 and aqp7 were found to be common
between differentially expressed ppar
signaling pathway and officially
expressed transcription factor pp arg
lep and lipe were found to be common
between differential express ampk
signaling pathway and differential
express factor pt arg
adipoq and cd36 were found to be common
for differentially expressed ppar and
ampk signaling pathway and cd 36 was the
only differential express gene found
common between the above three
not only that it was also found that
these genes were all uh degraded
downregulated differentially expressed
genes
we then moved on to gene mania to
predict the function of the
differentially expressed cd36 gene found
common among all the above mentioned
statutes
g in mania finds other genes that are
related to a set of input genes using a
very large set of functional association
data
association data includes protein and
genetic interactions pathways
coexpression co-localization and protein
domain stability
the network produced involved 83.5
zero percent of co-expression denoted in
lilac
six point four one percent of physical
interactions denoted in pink
three point five eight percent of
co-localization denoted in purple
two point seven two percent of predicted
values denoted in orange
2.48 of pathways denoted in blue 0.96
percent of shared protein domains
denoted in yellow and 0.43 percent of
genetic interactions denoted in green
from the above experiment we concluded
that the set of genes that were found to
be differentially expressed namely fabp4
aqp7 lep lipe
adipoq and cd36
cd36 gene holds the potential to serve
as a diagnostic test for the purpose of
early detection of prostate cancer
in addition pparg transcription factor
in association with map cave map kinase
one and map9s3 can also be looked at as
a potential proteomic biomarkers to
precipitate in the diagnosis of prostate
cancer
however further analysis needs to be
performed on these genes to understand
if they can be used in fusion with some
other genes to increase their
selectivity and specificity thank you